next question today david if trump does
delay the
the election can you tell me
definitively who becomes president
i've heard nancy pelosi i've heard chuck
grassley i don't really understand
okay so this came up briefly in a
voicemail earlier this week but let's go
through it again
if donald trump delays the election
enough and again
i i'm not debating here whether he can
do it
how it could be done how much he would i
don't want to do that stuff because
there's all sorts you know the
the electors have to vote i believe it's
in the first half of december
and there's other dates and elections
are run by the states these are 50 state
decisions more than they are anything
that donald trump would do
so let's skip that piece for now but
let's imagine
we get to january 20th and there has not
been an election
trump doesn't stay in power trump stops
being the president
now when you look at the line of
succession okay it would go from
president to vice president but mike
pence
also would no longer be vice president
well then it would go to the speaker of
the house
nancy pelosi well if the election in
california doesn't happen
she is no longer elected so
she's no longer speaker of the house so
it would skip her
so eventually it would go to the senate
pro tem
now currently the senate pro tem is
chuck grassley
a republican because republicans have
the majority in the senate
but the problem is that 35
senate seats are up for election in
november of the hundred senate seats
if those 35 elections don't happen
again we're assuming none of the
elections happen you might have some
states do the election but not enough
to select the president but let's skip
that for now
if those 35 senate seats end up being
open
you now only have 65 senators
and that means that the democrats would
have a majority because republicans have
far more seats to defend in november
than do democrats so if none of these 35
elections happen
republicans lose more seats than
democrats you then have
no president no vice president no house
but you have a senate made up of the 65
remaining senators
who are more than 50 percent democrats
meaning democrats
get to select a senate pro tem who
becomes the president
until this is resolved now historically
again this is our best understanding
producer pat and i have been researching
this this is our best understanding
historically senate pro tem tends to go
to the most senior
um senator from the party right now
that's vermont's patrick leahy
however it's conceivable that if the 65
remaining senators knew
that by electing a senate pro tem they
were essentially
selecting the next president it's
conceivable they would pick someone
other than patrick leahy but
that's the scenario as i best understand
it today
that would determine who is president if
we don't have a presidential election in
november now
let me go back to what i said when i
commented on james clyburn earlier this
week saying i think trump is going to
after he loses you some kind of
emergency to stay in power
i believe that our coverage of that
possibility
needs to focus around the idea that the
mere suggestion of delaying a federal
election which has never happened
is a despotic authoritarian dystopian
nightmare
um the the now that we
i was asked the question what exactly
would happen i've answered it to the
best of my ability i don't think that's
where the focus should be the focus
should be
that trump even floating this idea is
completely outrageous we vote in this
country
we figure out how to do it states are
expanding absentee ballot access
universal absentee voting as i'm calling
it uh
and we're going to have an election and
donald trump is going to either win
or not win and things are going to
happen on the schedule they're supposed
that has to be the default conversation
once you start engaging in what would
justify delaying it or what would be the
mechanism for delaying it
academically it's interesting but it's
problematic when
it becomes a corporate media dialogue
which only legitimizes
the idea at its core so that's my take
on that